Monsieur Godiva box uber juste visiblement
trop souvent tu bousilles un robinet Nestlé
c'est un film sexy
c'est le flux et le reflux de la passion et du
contrôle vois la fusée c'est un docteur
merde ma solution l'industrie de Joe helix
Burke t'as fait c'est à propos de deux personnes
qui essaient de  trouver un lien dans une
collection et essayer de surmonter ce
problème de la façon dont il mène sa vie
rasam multimètre de réplique Ducati Anastasia
déverrouille ce côté complet de lui et il enfreint
tellement de ses propres règles
Kiska qu'elle a un effet sur lui que personne d'
autre n'est dur  cela ressemble à un conte de
fées
même si c'était une version très adulte
ils ont un lien indéniable
ils n'ont jamais aimé quelqu'un
autant qu'ils s'aiment